welcome back the DNC reportedly dropping
its sponsorship of the women's March
after one of the group's leaders refused
to denounce Nation of Islam leader Louis
Farrakhan here's the heated exchange
that took place today on the view I
didn't call him the greatest of all time
because of his rhetoric I called him the
greatest of all time because of what
he's done in black communities I don't
agree with many of Minister Farrakhan
statement specifically about Jewish
people as I said I don't agree with many
of Minister Farrakhan statements to
condemn that me I don't agree with these
statements at the end of the day
well condemn it no no no to be very
clear it's not my language it's not the
way that I speak it is not how I
organize I should never be judged
through the lens of a man so what you
saw there by the way that was Monday
night yes not today but what you see
there is representative of a larger
movement away from the march by Southern
Poverty Law Center EMILY's List Human
Rights Campaign national abortion rights
League Center for American Progress all
these left-leaning groups that had
supported the march remember they turned
out millions in the immediate aftermath
of the inauguration pulling away what do
you make of this well I know credit
where credit is due right good for them
for disassociating with the women's
March and especially individuals who are
anti-semitic right and make a McCain did
an awesome job in that interview and
really holding her feet to the fire
Malika and asking for an explicit
condemnation and Malik of refused to
give Megan and the country that so I
think that is a big problem the left has
a Louis Farrakhan problem and they also
have a problem with some anti-semites
among the group you even have Maxine
Waters who was you know there's a video
recently of her hugging Louis Farrakhan
she is the chairwoman of the Financial
Services Committee it shouldn't be that
hard to condemn a guy who says that Jews
are termites and compares them to Satan
it really shouldn't be that hard Brian I
think a lot of people in the black
community approach the bluest
Farrakhan's anti-semitism but Louis
Farrakhan and the Nation of Islam have
always engaged poor people in jail and
sometimes help those people in their
lives so not saying that every person
who is evil doesn't do any good for the
most part Farrakhan might have some
attributes in the black community but
anybody's looking to do something broad
base has to
associate and for them to go on the view
and think that they could make these
statements and not make clearly feel let
it be known hey for example he does
things in the black community but I am
Pro I am I am NOT for his anti-semitic
behavior as anti white talk I am Pro it
just get the they get the lines down at
the very least she had was not prepared
to just associate yourself and now a
program that a Mart's that had 550
sponsors is down to half that and might
not even take place on Sunday it's
unbelievable the the fret being friends
with Louis Farrakhan can destroy a life
a career a program and in this case a
woman's March is it worth it that's the
that's the question but I think it's
very difficult for people who are trying
to achieve solidarity as part of the
anti-trump resistance but Dana the
question then becomes if this is about
race what about what's going on with
Steve King this week and the Republican
ranks you don't you know you saw them
pull committee assignments from him but
he's not being forced out he's not being
sprung out of the Congress well but how
would they do that right so he's been
elected they can say they can do as much
punishment as they well and it might
come to that there's a race to get to
the moral high ground right and the
guilt by association this has been going
on for a long time right so if you're a
part of this group or this part of that
then you must agree with all of those
things but the Farrakhan piece is is
pretty interesting
I'm and so is the Steve King piece you
have somebody like Liz Cheney who is the
conference chairman for the Republicans
saying you gotta get you should find
another line of work right to draw
they're drawing a line in the sand and I
feel like maybe the Democrats smell
blood in the water like they want the
Republicans to hurt because of Steve
King but then the Republicans could turn
on say well what about Louis Farrakhan
and then like where does it end and I do
also agree there is a personal choice
right I don't have to own everything
that anybody that has ever been a
Republican has ever said I don't have to
own any of that like I I can choose my
own path and I do that every you make a
choice 20,000 times a day every time you
open your mouth how would you handle
this I think the biggest problem with
Reverend Farrakhan is that he did not
evolve there was a time when that
rhetoric was to fight for rights there
was an ugly in the 1670s it was it was a
different world now your he should have
evolved and to convey
his aunt I she needed to do that you can
still support the things that he did but
he didn't evolve he stayed in the lane
that we're not trying to be anymore so
you cannot support Farrakhan and then
condemn somebody for supporting King you
just can't do it
if a guy wants to be pro white and he
wants to say bad things about
african-americans and Jewish people but
he's really good at balancing the budget
you don't see that make that argument
and you like you can't do that because
he's white it's the same thing we've
come a long way it's the same playing
field now a lot more than it was thirty
years ago when that rhetoric and his his
fight and his vigor was important to the
black community he needed to evolve he
should have been containing the way he's
speaking now because it's a different
world now and you can't ask for change
if you're not willing to change I'm
sorry I was just gonna say it real quick
before Twitter or media it comes after
me Tamika Mallory I said the wrong name
so I apologize I think that a lot of
people agree with you and by the way I
think the Jewish and black community
with the forefront of civil rights era
so I don't know that's changed but I
think that this is a cult group in many
ways I know they you know they come out
outerspace and stuff but it's a problem
now up next twenty twenty Democratic
contenders using Stephen Colbert's show
as a late-night launching pad to stand
out from the pack of aspiring Candace
that's next on the fire